пере мичча ニャーニバヴィッサンティ マヤ メッタ サッマ ニャーニバヴィッサマティ サッレコーカラニーヨ
他の人々は他人はミッチャニャーニ
間違っている知恵を持っている人々である
じゃ 智者というかね 知識は間違っている
知識を得ていると しかし
そこをここで我々は承知者になるように
正しい知恵があるようにと自分自身を戒めますという意味なんですね
そこで出ている言葉はミッチャニャーニ
ニャーナっていうのは知恵のことで
知識というふうに思っても構いませんし
知識か知恵かなんです
そちらにも 2つありますね
ミッチャ間違っている知識とサンマ正しい知識という 2つあるんです
そこで仏道の人から見れば
世の中はミッチャニャーニ
それと間違っている知識ではないかと
これあの 間違っていると言っても
少々訳できない言葉なんですけど
で とにかく注釈書ではニャーニっていうのは何かを観察して出てくるものであると
ですから 知識とは違うんでしょうね
知識っていうのは何か勉強して得るもので
いろんなことを勉強してから
私たちはまたそこから何か発見したりするんですね
勉強するものをしたものを観察したり
さらに考えたり さらに実験したり
さらに研究したりして
いろいろものを発見する
で 例えば養老孟司という
日本で大変立派な先生がいるんですね
で 知識抜群な人で で その先生の分野は解剖学なんですね
遺体をもうごちゃごちゃ切って
あれいろんなことをして調べることであって
で その中からその人がやっぱりこの脳の勉強しようではないかと
自分で進んで それで脳の研究もすると
そこで脳細胞はどうやって働くかとか
この解剖学的にはもう知識なんですね
しかし そこからその先生がいろんなものを観察して
智慧を得ているんですね
その一般人向けに書いている本というのは
全部その先生が自分で発見して考え出した智慧というところなんです
決して学問的な医学生にテキストを書いているわけじゃないんです
だから その先生の知識が我々になくても
どんな素人にもその先生書いてる
何でも脳が決めるものやとかね
とにかくいろいろ本があるんですね
そういうどんな本でもとっても簡単に読まれますよ
理解もできるんです その先生の本は抜群に理解できたんだからって
我々は解剖学者になったんですかね
まるっきりわからないね
その世界は しかし その養老先生が自分の知識に基づいて自分にも教えてくれなかった先生たちも自分にも教えたんだからね
そういう先生たちにもなかった別な新しい世界を
新しい哲学というか 新しいものの見方というかね
新しい人生観というか
何かをもう新しく作っているんですね
そこら辺は智慧の世界なんです
だから知識に基づいて何かね
あの といいますか クリエイティブに
このクリエイティブで何かを作り出すというところが
そういう風にこの 2つはあるんですよ
ただ 勉強しただけでは知識であって
知恵というものはないんですね
そこで 世の中で私たちは生きている上で役に立つということは
知恵であって知識ではないんです
ただ勉強しただけでは生きてはいられません
勉強だけの人だったら
まあ自分が覚えたものは全部暗記するなりにノートに書くなり
またそのまま繰り返して言うしかできないんですよ
で 生きている上では このいろんなことを勉強したならば
そこは生きている上でいろんな方法で使わなくてはいけないんですね
そこが賢の智慧は智慧であって
役に立って それで生きているんですよ
面白いことは 知識っていうのはわかりませんね
私たちには 特に私には
例えば医学的な専門的なことをいくら言ったってもさっぱりわからない
医大の授業なんかに行って参加したっても
参加させてくださいと言ったら
まあどうぞそこどこかに座ってくださいと言われるかもしれませんだけど
でもさっぱりもわからないんでしょうね
数学の授業に行って座ったっても
まあずっと睡眠薬にはなりますけど
何の勉強になりません
しかし 数学者が何か本を書く
それが読んでわかるんですよ
だから 養老孟司先生の知識の世界は
もうさっぱり こちらにはもう関係もない
わかるものでもないんだけど
その先生が書く本なんかは
まあ何のことなく見事に読んで理解できる
ということは 智慧っていうのは
ある時ての訓練がなくても使えるんですよ
専門家でなくても 素人にも誰にでも使える
だから養老孟司先生が提案するあらゆる生き方っていうのは
誰にでも理解もできて実践もできる
しかし 大学の講義はまあ避けた方がいいんです
それはあんまりその専門的に勉強する学生さん以外は関係ないんですね
だから知識は狭いんですよ
どんな知識からも出てくる智慧は誰にでも役に立ちます
アインシュタインにしても
彼の論文なんかはもうもうもう
それは勉強している人にしかわからないんですよ
しかし アインシュタインさんが一般的に書いている
自分のあらゆる知恵 知識をさらに観察して
一般人に対してまた何か何か言ったり書いたりする
手紙書いたりとかする
それが誰でもびっくりするほど
もうすごい頭切れる言葉なんですね
ということで 智慧っていうのは生きてる上で欠かせないもので
みんな生きてるんだから
みんなにそれは理解できる
知識は専門的なもので
一部なんですね いつでも役に立つっていうわけじゃないんです
[背景音楽]そういうことで
こちらで こちらで言うニャーニー
智慧の定義は そういうふうな定義になるんです
だから知識というわけでもないんです
知識から芽が出て実る別なものなんだ
だから知識はこの やっぱり土台なんですね
知識という土の上で何か芽が出て花が咲いて実るという何かあるんですね
これがみんなに役に立つと
それなのに そこで仏教はそちらにも二つ分けるんですね
ミッチャーとサンマーと
で 仏教の分け方っていうのは
大きくは道徳的なんですね
まぁ完璧に道徳的に分けるということをしない時もありますけど
だから大体ほとんどの場合というかね
道徳的に正と邪にしていくんですね
だから仏教で間違っているといえば
これは道徳的な目で見ると正しくない
という意味になるんです
だから智慧はニャーニーはいいんだけど
道徳の基準から見ると
尺度から見ると良くないと
はっきり判断できることなんです
そういうわけで 世の中の知恵
私たちはもう大変理解したり
ありがたがったり 人生のために使ったりはしています
仏教から見れば 世の中っていうのは本当にミッチャーニャーニーではないかと
智慧はあることはあるんだけど
道徳的な尺度で見ると
基準から見ると違うと
ですから いくら素晴らしい知恵であろうとも言っても
ありがたがるってはなくて
私たちはもう初宗派かもしれませんだけど
もう頑張って努力するんだと
サンマーニャーニーになるために
だから道徳的にも正しい智慧を作るために頑張ろうではないかと
そこで養老孟司先生のことを言いましたから
やっぱり結構前からその先生が言っていた脳の働きで
どこかでみんなこの制限するんだと
脳の能力には 脳っていうのはものを知る機械なのに
どこかでもう自分でブレーキをかけて
知ることをリミット 制限するんだと
で それで知識の制限とかね
なんとかとか言うと ちょっとあまり面白くないんですね
智慧としては 一般人はもうあまりそれで理解してくれないんですね
それで彼が開発した言葉っていうのは
このバカの壁っていう言葉なんですね
で バカの壁っていう言葉を開発した途端
みんないきなり分かってしまうんですよ
だからすごくすごい智慧なんですよ
あれは脳の働きはあれやこれやとか言って
そこでその働きの中から自動的に制御化しているんだと
この制御化が入ったところで脳が開発しないので止まってしまいますよということが学問的な話なんです
これは誰にも面白くないんです
誰にも面白くないし 勉強したらすぐ忘れちゃう
そこで知恵を出して バカの壁という
これみんなにあるんだよと
これでみんなもうなんだこれと読んでみると
みんなこうやって自分で壁を作って
その壁の向こうは知ろうとはしないんだと
[笑い]で 彼が推薦するのは
このバカの壁を作ることはもうちょっとやめたらどうでしょうかと
という推薦なんですね
もっと力があるんじゃないですかと
脳には で そこでこの現代人のこの生ぬるい生き方やらね
もうわがまま放題で もう発展というか
新しい考え方を作るとか
堂々ともう頑張って生きると
これまるっきりない だから彼が例に出すのは自分の生徒たちの話でしょうしね
こんな人々は医者にしていいのかと
自分でももう不満でたまらんというね
これほどバカですかと
だから彼がこの社会のある危険性
特に日本の社会は 現代社会はもうかなり危険な方向を向いているんだと
成長しない方向を向いているんだと
というところで 社会に何かもう役に立つことは言ってます
だからできるだけバカの壁を作らない方がいいっていうことです
そこである人に私は全く関係ない
色々質問されちゃって
そちらにサッとこの養老孟司の言葉をね
入れてあげたんです で
私は何を書いたかというと
なんだかんだも知る必要はないんだと
確実にバカの壁は必要ですよと
で 養老先生がこのバカの壁を発見する前に
随分昔 お釈迦様がそれを発見していたんだと
そこでバカの壁をどこで
あの 何て言いますか 作りますかと
で そこを書いてるんだと
だからブッダのところになってくると
ある日突然 人間の心にバカの壁ってあるんではないかと発見したわけじゃないんで
さらに進んでバカの壁を作れと言っているんです
で 作る場合でも随分明確に建築設計も書いているんです
作り方まで で そこまで書けません
だからね 私はこういうバカの壁が必要だという風に返事は出しましたけど
やっぱり心配して私には理解できないんだと
あの先生の話は で これは言おうとは悩んでいたんですけどという返事があったんです
あの養老先生はこのバカの壁はこの評価してないんだと
ですから 私の理解はね
どうかなと思いますよと
で どう返事すればいいかと
だから私は相手にならんなと
こういう人々っていうのはね
だからその先生考えてる次元じゃないんですよと
こちらで考えているのは
とにかくまあ返事は出しましたけどね
それぐらい知ってるんだよと
その先生はね まあ俺 俺にこれできる？マジでやるの？というね
腰抜けのいい加減なね
若者にしっかり頑張れというぐらいの話でしょう
それはと そんなのはわかってるんだと
私が言ってるのはそういうことじゃないんだと
知ると言えば全宇宙のことも知るでしょうしと
生命のことだったら完全に生命って何なのかと知るんではないかと
この完全知の問題だと
だから完全たる知の場合
世界ではそういい加減で何でもかんでもということではいけないんだと
明確にやって知っても意味の意味のないものにはきちんと壁を作って
知るべき世界 全知を完知を目指して行かなくちゃいけないんだと
ですから これ次元の違いの話だよと
しかし ただ単に私 私には面白かっただけだとその概念は
なぜならば もし私が私のように何の研究もしない人がみんなに向かってバカの壁ではないかと言ったら
それは侮辱だと 個人に対しては
しかし その研究者がちゃんと研究して概念を作ると
侮辱でも何でもないんだと
だから使っただけですよと
人の概念はね 私は言っているのは
あの俗世間ではなくてはならない
バカの壁は高次元で考えてみると
あっ 何でしたっけ あってはならない
俗世間ではなくてはならないものは
高次元の世界ではあってはならないということになるんだから
ただ面白かっただけですよと
これでわかってくれるかどうかわかりませんですけどね
まあそれはまああの現代若者たちと
まあ若者だから 一応そういうところは丁寧に私は書いてありますけど
しかしもう私も疲れますね
もし自分が教えてる時代であんな生徒がいたらね
もう机でもぶん殴って頭に送りたくなるんじゃないかなと思うぐらいなんですね
だから先生も結構嫌になって
もう金がくれるんだから教えなくちゃいけないし
でも嫌な仕事でしたでしょうと思いますけど
まあだからこのそれで知恵って
道徳的にあのミッチャーとサンマに分ける場合は
まあ大体仏教は俗世間の知恵やらインスピレーションやらね
そういうものっていうのはそれほど正しくはないんだと
なぜ正しくないんだというと
世間がこの自分が例え養老先生みたいな
またいろいろ哲学者やらね
思想家やらいっぱいいるでしょうに
その人々はもうみんなに素晴らしいことを言うんだけど
そこから何に導くかと
もう例えば養老先生から見ても
全部まとめて単純化して言えばね
しっかり頑張れという言葉でしょうに
もう こんな調子ではダメだよと
役に立たんぞという意味でしょうし
何に役に立つかというと
結局俗世間のために役に立つことで
いっぱい金儲かりましょうという言葉と大して変わりはないんですよ
例えば あの養老先生みたいな立派な方ではなくて
まあくだらないどこかのおじさんがいて
やっぱりいっぱい金儲けなくちゃあかんぞとかね
何でもいいから金儲けなさいよと
金さえあれば何でもできるぞという話と
そんなに変わりはないんですよ
なぜかというと 金儲けろということを
人もこの世の中でうまく幸せで必要なものを買って生きることを目指しているんですよ
それで知識儲けしなさいという人も
結局は俗世間でより豊かで生きるという目的しか考えてないんです
だからその 2つでそれほとんど似ているんですよ
そこのそこまでは別に悪くないんですよ
で さらに知恵を働かせて
激しく競争して戦って成功
成功する世界 ほとんどそういう世界でしょうに
戦って壊して自分だけ成功している世界
だから無理と思わないよと
選挙に出るんだったら
もうもうまあ勝てないだろうと思わないで
手段どうでもいいんだから
もうもう勝っちゃいなさいよという話なんです
それで手段どうでもいいんだから
いろんな悪い手段を使って選挙で勝つと
勝ったところで その人は素晴らしいとみんなまあちやほやすると
だからそういう風な智慧の世界っていうのは決して正しくないんだよ
道徳的には ですから 悪いことをしても
あらゆる工夫をしてそれを正当化する知恵
で その知恵だからみんなにわかるように喋る
例えば人を殺すのは正しいと
アメリカの大統領様は
あの 単なるデータ出したならば
誰も聞いてくれないんですね
それでデータはないんだから
作品いろいろ作って あの
で イラクのことを全くも知らない
もうイラクから追い出された人々の怒り
憎しみの感情的な証言を聞いたりとか
で それでも一番品のない
もうまあどこらでも暗示かけられてマインドコントロールされて
麻原の弟子たちみたいな感じでアメリカ人に喋ると
そこで見事にマイソスということで
九十パーセントもうもう殺すことには賛成と
どこまで暗示かけられたかというと
フセインとあのビンラディンっていうのは同じ人間やと思ってるんですね
アメリカ人のほとんどは
まあ実際はビンラディンを育て上げて
あの土台作ってあげて
ずっと あの 何て言いますか
あの パイプラインというか
生命のね まあ作りっているのはサウジアラビアなんですけど
それが随分いい友人ですね
で 何のことなく把握できない
掴めないのはそういうわけなんです
サウジアラビアっていうのはイスラム世界ではね
かなりタッチできない
全くもうね アクセスできない国でしょうし
そこは一番いい あの 寄りかぶなんですよ
宗派争いもないし 何もないところでまたメッカがあるんだから
それはもう神の国なんですね
イスラム寺にとっては
どこかでアフガンやらどこら辺国でなんとかゴソゴソとテロが現れだしても
これは簡単に潰せますけどね
同じことをサウジアラビアで行うとテロという風にならないんですよ
そちらでは純粋に信仰に基づいて宗教を語る世界だから
まあこれはどうでもいいんですけど
そこですごくわかりやすく
世界に向かって喋って
アメリカ人はみんなと外国では一人二人ぐらいはもう納得させることはできたんですね
そこで反対している人々も力の論理で
やっぱりこれは賛成せざるを得ないということで
もうフランスやらいろいろ
どんどんどんどん参加していったりすると
てなきゃ自分の立場がなくなるんだと
そういうことで このこれもある一定の智慧なんですよ
知識じゃないんです 知識だったら即もうこれは嘘やとわかっちゃいますからね
みんなにわかるよう理解して
自分の方向へ暗示かけてくれるようにという風に喋るところは
もう知恵もどきの世界なんですね
例えばアメリカ人はあなた方は攻撃されてそれで我慢できますかと
あちこちで爆弾仕掛けて殺されると
あなた方どう思いますか？と言うと
我々のこの幸せを壊してはあかんぞと思っちゃうでしょうね
やっぱりそれはダメですよと
殺される前に殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
潰される前に潰さなくちゃいけないんだと
やられる前にやらなくちゃいけないんだという生き方をきちっと
もう成立させますね 結果としてはものすごい残酷に人が死んでいる
アメリカは豊かになるところじゃなくて
もう赤字で赤字で もう大変なことになっていて
だからどう見ても結果はいいわけじゃない
もうただ金のために軍隊に入ってるあの若者の連中はもう次から次へと殺されちゃう
戦争しているところじゃなくて
ただヘッドフォンで音楽聴いてるでしょ
ほとんど アメリカの若者たちだからね
まあ高校生ぐらいの人々でしょ
みんな だから元気でしょうし
体力もあるでしょうし
だから面白おかしく そういう生粋状況の中でいろんなことをやってみたいっていうだけの話なんですね
ここは落ちちゃうと ちょっと隙間が見えたところでもうやられちゃうし
隠れていて もう一方的に爆弾を落とすのはできましたけど
それでこういう中に入っちゃうと何一つもできなくなるんですね
だから結果っていうのは
人間のことを大事に思う人にとってはね
アメリカの兵隊さんもやっぱり若者ではないかと
元気で生きていてほしいんじゃないかなと
という親の気持ちで見ると
これはいい結果にはならないんですね
だから世の中の知恵っていうのは
そうやって欲 怒り 憎しみというものをあおいで立てる知恵なんです
だからミッチャーニャーニーと言うんです
そこで俗世間でもインスピレーションが欲しい
えーと いわゆるクリエーティブというものが欲しいとかね
みんな必死なんですよ
音楽大学に入ってる人々は
ただ技術だけ 知識だけはもう簡単に身につくんですけどね
音楽大学に入ったら 藝大に入っちゃうと
芸術の知識だけは 技法だけはね
随分簡単に身につくんですよ
でもそれでは食べてはいられないんですね
それでインスピレーションやらクリエイティビティというやつは必要になっちゃうんです
それは知恵の世界なんです
だから自分の作品を作ることに
そういう芸術家たちが一生懸命頑張る
学校は何を教えてくれたかというと
知識の部分だけ できるだけクリエイティブというね
創造的創作的なものには現れるようにはいろいろ援助やらしてはいるんだけど
これは明らかに本人の頭の中で現れてこないと
しかし その智慧っていうのは智慧かというと
ただ音楽的なっていうのは
いろいろ売れる作品 ヒット作品を作りたいだけで
ヒットしたらその人はそれで金儲かるっていうことだけなんでしょうに
だから明らかに金儲かっちゃえばいいというあのおじさんの話に戻るんですよ
結局は 金さえあればいいと
芸大で他の芸術作品を作る人でも
これ自分の作品ヒットしたら
これでもう世界的に認められちゃうと
それで生活は安定ということになるんですね
それには智慧がないとうまくいかない
歌は作れるんですけど
ヒットするかしないかっていうことはまたほとんど別な話で
だから 俗世間の智慧っていうのは
そうやって日常生活に必要な物質的な豊かさと人間に認めてもらうという気分的な豊かさ
その二つだけ目指している
そういうわけだから 仏教はそれはミッチャーニャーニ・ジャチシャということにしているんです
それで正しいというのは
完璧に道徳的に正しいものになるんですね
だから欲を燃やすんじゃなくて
欲を減らす 怒りを燃やすんじゃなくて怒りを減らす智慧
そのインスピレーション
そのクリエイティビティというもの
それが必要でしょうと
これは俗世間では考えられない思考パターンなんですね
で 戦争に勝ったならば
その勝った人々はヒーローに仕立てて
その戦略方法やらね これは本書いたり
素晴らしい人 なんて頭がいい人ですかと褒める場合は
これはミッチャーニャーニの世界なんですね
で 番目は ミッチャーですね
パリ ミッチャ ヴィムッティ バヴィッサティ マヤ メッタ サмма ヴィムッティ バヴィッサマティ サッレコ カラニヨ
他人はジャガ解脱を目指していると
我々はショーギャ解脱を目指すようにと戒めるということで
で ヴィムッティ解脱っていうのは
まあこれはまあ まあ解放ということで
救われるということで
これ世の中では まあ救われるっていうことにいろいろ考え方ありますしね
これさえあれば救われますよと
子供は試験だけ合格してもらえば
まあ私としたら救われますよとかねと言ったりするぐらいの救うっていうこと考え方はありますね
それでほっとするという意味なんですね
苦しみがなくなったと
で 大学も卒業した子供がいる場合は
まあなんとかどこかの会社でね
内定してもらえば まあもう救われますよと
で 親が言う せっかく親にとってはかなりこれは苦しい状況なんですね
そういう風に この いろんなところで我々は救いという言葉使ってます
まあ例えば重病の子供がいるとしますね
それで心臓が弱り心臓移植しなくちゃいけないとかね
腎臓移植しなくちゃいけないとかね
それでなきゃ この子はいつ死ぬかわからない
あるいはずっと外へ出ることもなく
ベッドで生活しなくちゃいけない
それで親はかなり苦しんでるんですね
そこで外国にでも連れて行って
もうなんとか腎臓心臓移植でもできてれば
まあ救われますよと と言ったりする
そういう時でも救いという言葉使っちゃうしね
で 日本の経済状況がね
バブルの時期に戻ったならば
皆様方はやっぱり救われましたと言うでしょうしね
だからこの結局救いということっていうのは
苦しみはなくなったっていう意味なんですよ
どこでどう見たっても
この救いと解脱っていうのは
日本語では全く違う漢字使ってますけど
まあパーリ語だったら同じヴィムッティというね
言葉で 2つも一緒に扱ってるんです
だから自分で自分を救うか
救ってもらうかというところでちゃんと区別をする
だから救ってもらう世界には日本語で救いの言葉を使うし
自分で自分を救うことには解脱って言葉を使うんですね
で 元のパーリ語だったらほとんど同じ単語なんです
使うのは だからムッチャティということ動詞だから
ムチというのはもうリリースというね
何かから離れるっていうことですから
やっぱり苦しみから離れるんですね
脱出っていう意味なんですね
だからまあ そこで世の中で救いという言葉を使うと
やっぱり仏教の道徳から見ると
まあこれがあまり良くないと
そこで仏道を歩む人々はまた別に正しい
完全に道徳的に正しい救いと解脱というものを目指している
そこで俗世間見ると 人間にとっては最高の幸せ
苦しみを全くなくなった状態って何なのかと一人一人に聞くと
一人一人が自分なりの考え方を持ってるんですね
で 一般人に聞けばろくな答えが出てこないんですけど
例えば前説明したように
まあ自分にとってはもう子供が合格してくれればね
この で救われますよというぐらいの話で
では その母親に後で聞いてみると
また違うことを言う可能性もあります
だからろくな答えが出てこないんですね
例えば合格したのは良かったんです
それで救った気分になったんです
救われた気分になったんですけど
そこで大学でふざけてバカなことやってると聞いちゃうと
その同じ母親がやっぱり無事大学卒業してくれれば
もうこれが救えますよ
救われますよと言っちゃうんです
だから変わっちゃうんですよ
だから一般的に個人個人に聞けばろくな答えが出てこない
その時悩んでいる一番悩んでいる問題を出したりする
しかし もうちょっと物事を考える人はもうちょっと違う答えを出すかもしれません
そこでも人間 なんで宗教にそんなに興味を持っているかというと
はっきりしないんですね
ただ単にこの固定概念で伝統的に必要だというふうに思っているだけで
本気じゃないと思いますけどね
で 宗教に興味を持つのは
いろいろ人々がいてね
世の中でいろんなことにチャレンジはして
チャレンジはして もううまく一つもいかない
そこで得体の知れない
全く曖昧も曖昧な宗教の世界に入り込んじゃって
そこでチャレンジをする必要ではないかというね
人々もいるし 例えばこの世の中はあまり良くないんだとかね
もう若者まで今殺しになってるんではないか
こんな教育あるのに何だこの結果はとかね
やっぱりこれ精神世界は無視しているんだからと
もうこれもうこれからはやっぱり心の時代だとか
そういうふうにいい加減なことを言って
そこで宗教に興味を持つというのは
明らかにこれあれこれやったみたいなところでうまくいかなかったんですね
いろいろ失敗しちゃったんですよ
世界一基準の教育システムやっていて
威張ってはいたんだけど
結果見ると人殺ししか作ってないんです
全く仕事もできない もうマニュアルがなければもう動けない
もうもうもうもういい加減なロボットばっかり作っているとかね
それよりこの世界一基準高いの教育って何なのかと言っても
自分でわからない この教育システム変えるぐらいの能力はインスピレーションはない
だから別に何も悪くないんだよと
この教育はと 改良するところがないんだよとかね
で 考えたって矛盾にぶつかるんですよ
例えば 子供たちには心の余裕がない
遊ぶ暇がない だからこの勉強する日にち減らしてあげましょうと
土曜日休ませてあげましょうと
いい考え方だなとかね
突然飛び上がっちゃって
次に土曜日休んじゃったら教育どうするんですかねとか
今も教育レベルが下がっているのに
その上土曜日休ませちゃうとさらに下がるんではない
では反対と はい 分かりました
それで取り消して元に戻っただけな
だからそこでこの自分の力なささとかね
力の不足っていう新しいインスピレーションが出てこないというところがまあ見えてくるんですね
そう見えてくると また突然突発的に
これは精神を無視しているんだからと
ヨーロッパだったらちゃんと宗教的なことを教えているんではないかと
やっぱり心の時代だったら
では何を教えればいいかと
これでまたぶつかっちゃうんです
日本の子供たちには じゃあ何を教えればいいかと
出てこないでしょ 答えは
結局出てくるのはキリスト教を教えるべきだよということでしょうね
そういうことを教え始めちゃった途端
子供たちはいろいろ辛口言っちゃうんですね
だから明確に現れた時点からもう嘘やっていうことはわかってる教えでしょうね
言ってることは これが子供たちに言っちゃっても
今更の子どもたちはね
そんなの信じるわけじゃないし
そこであれやこれやとか
なんとかなんとか いい加減な徹底した偏見で書かれた
もうどんな宗教でもということで何か教えたりして
これで子どもたちにとっては一番面白くない授業になったりするし
これでもう宗教を教えるということを言ったっても
何を教えればいいか これは問題だとかね
やっぱりやめましょうと
で やめることになる また元に戻るんです
って面白いんですよ この無能な生き方っていうのは
で そういう人々の中で一部が宗教に興味を抱いて
もう何でもいいんだから何かに引っかかっちゃって
それをやる それでそれこそ世界だとか
またえらい勘違いまでして
社会に迷惑までかけたりもするしね
だから人間での本気かと
この精神的な世界に興味あるっていうことは私は疑問に思うんですよ
それでヨーロッパみたいにこのびっしりと宗教は教えてくれる
もう全て宗教一色でやっているね
国々では アメリカはえらい自由でしょ？でもプロテスタントでないとね
大統領にはほとんどなってはならないような気持ちはあるんですよ
だからど派手に言うんですね
ケネディ家が大統領になるとカトリック教だから
だからケネディ一人にしか大統領をさせなかったんです
他の人と殺しちゃうんです
ジョン・F・ケネディはなかなかもう大物でしたからね
もう潰せる でも殺しちゃったんでしょうね
大統領になることは全く
もうこれはもうストップできなかったんです
あまりにも人格者で  そんなもんで
だからもう宗教一色の国々というも
ヨーロッパ全部そうでしょうし
中東も全くもそうでしょうし
ではそこら辺でうまくいってますかと
みんな本気で宗教を信じているんですかとという疑問があるんですよ
例えばビンラディンに対してイスラム教って何でしょうかね
仏さんに対してキリスト教って何ですかね
だから誰もそんなのはスタディもしないでしょうに
結局は仏さんに対してはもうキリスト教というのは自分がやりたいことを正当化するための単なるもう一つの手段に過ぎないんですよ
それで自分たちは神様に守られているんだと
これをやらなくちゃいけないんだと
これをもう神の何て言いますか
この何とか何とか言うでしょうに
この同じこと ヒットラーという人も言ったでしょうに
自分は選ばれているんだと
だからヒットラーがもう好き勝手にひどい独裁政権を作りたかった
この独裁政権を作るためにはいろいろハンディが出てくる
そこで宗教を出しちゃって
宗教一色の国だからうまくいく
だからイスラム教系でも宗教一色だから
もうテロで殺しに「あんた行って自爆しなさい」と言っても誰もやりませんよ
そんなことは その上でみんなやりたくないんだから
勇気を出してテロ活動をさせるために
まあ宗教を道具に使う
だからはっきり言えば
ただ鍋が熱いんだったら
あれやあれ 何て言いますか
手に何か熱い手袋みたいなものを作る
で 使うでしょ  鍋つかみ
鍋つかみ  鍋つかみですか
何と言いますか あの熱い手袋に
え？鍋つかみ？鍋つかみ
そんなもんですよ 宗教っていうのは
人間にとっては 熱いものを触るための鍋つかみみたいなもんなんです
例えば ヨーロッパではね
宗教一色だからはっきりしています
で 日本というのはそういう形式的な宗教っていうのはない世界だからね
だからもう平気で嘘を言ってますね
日本というのは宗教的な国ではありませんと
しかし 宗教的といえば
日本ほど宗教的な国はないんです
向こうはもうだいたいはもうもうわかってますからね
これはもう こんなために使ってるんだとか
日本の場合はもう宗教一つじゃないんだから
ご利益あれば何でもいいやと
という態度でアプローチするんですね
だからもうそこら辺でこの排他性がないんだからね
もう人を殺したりはないんですよ
宗教っていうのはもうはっきりと排他性だから
二つは同じところには入れませんと
アッラーを信じるか ジェホワを信じるか
どちらかにしなさいと
私のこれこそ本当の唯一の神よと言わなくちゃいけないんだから
唯一の神が二人いるんだということになりませんだからね
だから排他性です 宗教は
で 日本の場合はこの排他性はないんだから
もうまあ誰でもいいんだから
ご利益だけくれと ということで
ご利益を期待して 宗教にはものすごい興味を持っている
そこで宗教プロパーという態度から見ると
これは宗教徒としてはちょっと醜いんですね
見つかりにくいんですね
しかし 私の解消から見れば
ただ生きると向こうでももう戦いたいブッサンが
これでやっぱりこれは悪いでしょうと言ってくるけど
やっぱり神を出しちゃうと
みんな「あ そうですか
ではやりましょう」ということになる
イラク人にしてみたっても
こんなアメリカに歯が立たないではないか
だから潔く抱腹して もう全部任せちゃえば
もうもう自分で蒔いた種をね
もう一番アメリカに対して勝つ方法っていうのはそれなんです
全部やってくれと言って協力してあげることが一番いいと思います
一人も死にませんし アメリカのあの子供たちも死なないし
それで悪いことした人はその分は悪い
苦労はしなくちゃいけない
そこでアメリカはイラクの開発に結構頑張らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
それで協力 全面的に協力しちゃうと
あれ？不正的なことにも口を出せますし
だからそういうことで
この わかりやすく言えば
野生のゾウが頭がおかしくなっちゃって
村に入って村を壊そうとしていると
もう村人はあっちこっち来て野生のゾウを導く
どこか行こうと そちらに行けないように何とか言って
それでゾウはどうしても壊すんだから
そこで導くところに行った時
何か建物なんかを壊すんだけど
本当は村人それを壊して欲しかったんです
でも自分たちには力がない
どうせ壊しに来たぞだから
じゃあそちらにっていう風に行かしちゃうと
ゾウが踏ん張って尻尾を上げていって
そこをむちゃくちゃ食わして
ああすいません また森に帰るでしょうに
村人もああよかったと
ゾウは正気に戻りましたし
我々もこういう壊したいところがいっぱいありまして
潰してくれますし ということになりますからね
でもそういうふうな すごく面白くて
しかし正しい智慧っていうのは
人間にはなかなか出るはずはないんですよ
ということで 日本の社会ででも学校試験の競争は激しいわ
会社の競争は激しいわ
奥さん同士の見栄やらいろいろは激しいわ
この競争というのはすごい面白いことで
例えば友達二人でも一人に子供が生まれて
一人に子供が生まれない
それだけでもう見栄が出てきたり
悩みの種になったりはしますよ
競争的な心で 時々女性には子供まだですか？と軽々聞くんだけど
聞かれる側っていうのはどんな気分かと
大変ですよ 人間の世界っていうのは
そういうことだから やっぱり子供が欲しいんだけど
みんな親ももう両家の人々も友達も子供まだですかとか何とか言われると
もう女性としてはもうもうすごいプライド潰されちゃって
しかしそれ言うこともできない
向こうに怒ることもできない
向こうは別に嫌な気持ちで聞いてるわけじゃないんですよ
向こうも本当に期待しているんだから
早く孫の顔見たいという
だから嫌な気持ちで聞いてるわけでもないんですけど
聞かれる側にとっては
もういても立ってもいられない
ものすごい精神的な苦痛にはなる
これどうにもならんだから
それで神社に行って もう子宝に恵まれるお守りを買ってくる
そこでその人はあの神社もう大変信仰しているんだとかね
あの霊場も大変信仰しているんだと言っても
私がそれ本気かと疑問に聞きたいんですね
結局は俗世間でうまくいかなかった時
あれが鉄掴みに？あ？鍋つかみに使っただけなんです
なんかキッチングローブっていうんだけど
鍋つかみよりはその方がね
日本語の方がぴったりだよね
ケドしないで済む  だから人の宗教に対する興味っていうのはそれぐらいのもので
そこで宗教の方はごちゃごちゃ言うかもしれませんだけど
ゲラスやら何やらそれはどうったことはないんですね
日本人はもう必ずもう結婚だったら教会という風に決まっているんだから
日本文化では  すごいものないですよ
まあ八十パーセントやるんだったら何で
田舎の方に行ったら神社です
まあ統計的に見ると八十パーセント教会
するだけですよ  で なんか最近どこかのホテルがすごい人気あって
もう夜なんかね すごく明るくて
もう色々全部やっぱりそういう
やっぱり文化的には新婦さんがいて
もうバージンロードがあってという風にもうかなり固定はしているんです
文化じゃなくてファッションです
どうでもいいんだけど
そんなのは私は  ホテルはみんな
そうそう バカはバカだから
だからこの そこでそちらはもう神の話やら天国の話やら洗礼の話やらするかもしれません
しかし 結婚する側にとっては
もうただ結婚だけしてくれればいいということで終わっちゃうんですよ
だから教会に行って結婚する人は
本当に真面目に神を信じているかというと全然なくて
単なる鍋つかみだけで終わってるんですよ
だから神社に行ったっても同じことなんです
そういうことで 世間の人々は宗教に関心を持っているということは
本当に精神的に心を清らかにするとかね
人格を向上するという目的かという疑問があるんですよ
だから俗世間ではこれが救いだ
これが救いだと言っても
仏教は本当？という マジ？という
あなた方はマジですかと
という目で見ているんです
だからサンマアディミットってミッチャイモットって言って
２つは仏教の世界ではきちんと成立するんです
そこで だからその中でも真面目に神様を信じている人々も
稀かもしれませんだけど
いるんです そういう人々は真面目に天国に行きたいんですよ
じゃあそれは正しい救いではないかと
そうでもないんです ただ死にたくはない
それだけの話なんです
死にたくはないんだけど
死んじゃいますから では天国で永遠に
だからそういう真剣に神を信じて
真剣にお祈りをして 真剣に賛美をして
真剣に巡回を回っている人にしたっても
仏教からあなたマジ？という状態にはなります
そこでヒンドゥーの世界は輪廻という概念もあるでしょうに
業があって 人が生まれては死んで
生まれては死んでいくんだというね
あれももういい加減仏教からもうもう借りた言葉だから
使い方はダサい まずい
間違っているとキリがないんですよ
人の概念は受け入れるのはいいんだけど
もういいパッチワークだからね
でもデザインが良くないんですよ
それで彼らが提案するのは
これが嫌だからボンが 1 2
になってやるぞと それで全て創造するのはボンだから
その人と一緒になったら安全だという
だから殺されるのは嫌だったら
一番楽な方法というのは殺し屋の側に行くことでしょ
そういう理屈なんです
苦しみ輪廻の世界 嫌だったらそれのそれを作っている人のところに
そちら側に回せばもう大丈夫と
という理屈で それ見たっても結局はもうただ死んだりするのは嫌だからそちらに行きたがっているだけで
本当にマジですかと ということで
世の中で言ってる身仏解脱に対する考え方は
そうどうったことはない
欲の表れですよ あるいは怒りの表れなんですよ
欲が解脱として現れる
怒りが解脱として現れる
そういうことで 仏教の人々を絡めれば
世の中はそうやってミッチャーヴィモッティ
間違ってる解脱を真面目に考えているんですけど
人々はみんな 我々は何人かか
あるいは私一人だけはもう正しい解脱というもの
怒りの表れでもなく 欲の表れでもなく
無知の表れでもなく 何かないのかなと
というところに今しみてみると
そこで一つのセットが終わりますね
何か質問ありますか？早川さんに
たまたま目を覚ましてもいいんですよ
あったような気がしますけど
そこら辺で なかった  欲の表れじゃない解脱っていう
ん？だから今ずっと説明してたそういうことなんですよ
死にたくないっていうことはね
生きていきたいという欲でしょう
それで永遠の境地を考える
それは欲の表れです あれ
イスラム教の天国の話はね
日本語でやりますから
ちょっと読んでみてください
その天国っていうのは欲そのものの
もう総調の総調ですよ
だから何でも全てこのジハドという自己を破壊してね
もう自爆している人々には特別に神様のところ
特別なところがあるんだ
相当ね だからこの世で満たせない欲っていうのは
何でも限りなく満たせるんだよという世界ですよ
だから欲の表れなんです
読んでないんだったら理解できんと思いますけど
インターネットでやりますからね
読んでみてください 天国はどういうものかと
イスラム教の で あまりね
キリスト教の人々っていうのはね
あんまりそんな頭が良かったんじゃないんです
だからあんまりわからない
そんな人々 天国って何ものかと
イスラム教は後でできたもんだから
天国の話はちゃんと書いてます
キリスト教の方々はそれはどういう世界かとはわかってないんです
でもしっかり頑張ろうとはしているんですけど
苦をなくしたいっていうのは
だから欲ではないっていうことですか？苦から逃れたいって
欲になる場合もあるし
まあどちらかというと欲にはなるんですよ
だから微妙なんだからすごい難しいんですよ
欲にならず苦をなくすという気持ちは
だからこれはもう初修派の初修派になるんです
だからこちら理論っていうのはみんなそういう世界ですけど
私は微妙に頑張ってそうならないようにという
で 答えはこういう答えなんで
仏教は全て捨てなさいという世界だからね
なぜ苦しみが生まれたかというと
束縛したんだから苦しみが生まれるんだと
はっきりする 例えば なんで子供が受験したら救われますかと母親は言うんですかね
子供に対するすごい執着
束縛あるんだからでしょうに
それで母親が受験する子供よりも苦しんでるんですよ
それは明らかに束縛から出てくる苦しみでしょ
その母親にあんた子供にはそんな執着するんじゃない
捨てなさいと言ったら執着捨ててくれる？絶対捨ててくれないでしょうに
殺されるかもしれない
そんなこと言われると
だから一切捨てるという世界は仏教ですから
捨てる場合は欲があると捨てられませんね
だから母親が明らかに知ってますよ
子供のことを一生懸命
もう欲も愛着もあるんだから
もう受験する子供より自分が苦しんでいるということ
だったら潔く執着を捨てなさいと言うと
これはやりませんね その代わりに何かどこかで合格祈願できるところがあれば
そちらに行くんです ということですからね
それから怒りの表れ 解脱やというね
もうわからないでしょ
で ユダヤ人は何で現れたんですかね
歴史的に  迫害されて  だから奴隷でいたでしょうに
それで怒りでもう我々は特別な人間でっていう風に突然考え出しちゃって
その人にリードされて
それからずっと人に目をかけてきてるんです
だからそういう人々に聞いてみたら
あなた方が言ってる天国はどんなものかとわからないんですよ
書いてないんです ユダヤ教でないんだから
キリスト教でもないんです
天国の説明は そこで麻薬中毒かどうか分かりませんですけど
黙示録なんか書いた人はね
あれかなりサイケデリックですけど
あれだったら誰も行きたくならない
あの天国には 恐ろしいでしょ？黙示録っていうのは
決して美しい世界じゃないんです
ですから この世の中が天国だと言ってるんですけど
本当にもう まあ今日はモリサナさん見ますから
ラジニッシュさんがすごく面白い話をしたところがあるんですよ
樹木ですね で そこに行って自分が何か希望するとすぐ叶うんです
だから天国です 悩むことはないんです
あれ欲しい これ欲しいという
だからそちらに人が木の下にもう天国に死んじゃって生まれたんですよ
生まれたその人は何か美味しいものを食べたいなと思った瞬間で
色々美味しいものがあるんだと
で この人はびっくりしちゃって
まあといっかという事で
これ食べては死んで また音楽でもあれば面白いなと思った途端
もうものすごいびっくりするほど音楽が聞こえてくるとか
またびっくりしちゃって
それでまた何か思った瞬間でまたもう出ていて
この人はあまりにもびっくりして
これ信じられなくて あれ
これは恐らく鬼の世界じゃないんでしょうかと
これえらい騙されて自分を殺されるかもしれない
思った途端殺されちゃって死んじゃったと
すっごくこの面白いエピソード
インドのエピソードは
彼がすごく面白くからかっちゃってるんですよ
茶化してるんです 人間っていうのはろくなものじゃないっていうことかもしれませんだけどね
言いたがってるのは だからまあ人間考えるというっていうのは
で まあどうったことはないなと思いますけど
そこはね まあ救いや何やと言ってもね
まああってくれたことではない
とにかく我々の欲の現れか
怒りの現れか 無知の現れか
どちらかがなります で
欲と純粋に貪瞋痴はいつでもね
まあサラダでもいろんなものを組み合わせて料理ですから
で まあカレーみたいなもんだからね
チキンカレーって言ったっても
チキンだけ チキンだけあるわけじゃないでしょうに
いろいろあるんですよ
ですから  しかしチキンカレーとは言います
ジャガイモとニンジンがあるにも関わらず
まあ次のここら辺で休もうかなと
何時間進んだんですか？ 今時間半です
ではちょっと休憩しましょう
よろしいですか それからこのもう一つ別なセットに入ります
これあの セットセットで道徳項目書いてるんですよ
だからこの暗記するときは
このあのセット このセットでちょっと頭にあると
ずっと並べて暗記できるんです
二十一番 パレティーナミッドパリユッティタバビッサンティマヤメッタヴィガタティーナミッドバビッサーマーティ
で 他人はだらけと これ何ですか？眠気に
眠気に陥るが 我々はだらけと眠気を断ち切るようにと戒めましょうと戒めましょう
まあこれはもうティーナっていうのはだらけで
ミッドっていうのは眠気で
まあ簡単です で これにこのパリユッティタっていうのは
そこはメインにして生きてるんですよ
人間というのは これ断ち切ろうという気持ちじゃないんですよ
よくよく我々の俗的な生き方を見ると
これが一番大事なんですよ
だからどうしようもなく何とかするんであって
だらけたいなと思ったらもうだらけてしまうんですよ
で 仕事をする時でも 早くこれをやめて
もうなんかだらけたいという気分があって
結局そこが衝動になってるんですよ
寝ることがすごい大事なことになって
もうそこまでの仕事なんですよ
仕事をしながらも早く寝たいなとか
早くこれを終わりたい
なんで早く終わったかというと
寝るためなんです だから仕事自体もそんなに面白くないんですよ
寝るためじゃなくて  だらけの目的に眠気があるってこと？ うん
だらけと眠気っていうのは
生物学的にはセットだから
だらけの次に眠気が出るし
だからそこでつなげてるんです
眠る前にはだらけが当然あるしね
だからセットにしていますけど
でも生き方としては 我々の生きる衝動はこれになっているんですよ
面白いことに だからそれは俗世間では本当は認めようともしないです
頑張ってるんだ 頑張ってるんだって言っちゃうしね
本当は生物学的に脳の働きから見ると
頑張ってるんだったらえらく面白くて
ものすごい明るくなるはずでしょうね
脳が回転機能すると 体も動くと
でも結果違うでしょうね
ものすごく疲れて 仕事して疲れて疲れて
もう嫌な状態になったという結果でしょうね
だからもう 2 日間も寝られなかった
もう大変だとかね そうなるはずがないんですよ
本当は だからこれはもう科学的科学法則も違反なんです
人間言ってることは ですから
この本当に我々の生きる衝動っていうのは
もうだらけて眠気がメインになって
その衝動で生きている
でもだらけ眠気だけではもう人生は成り立たないんだから
もうやむを得ずしょうがなく
頑張っていると ですから
こちらで言っているのは
人間みんなだらけてる
眠くてっていう意味じゃないんです
みんな寝ているんだぞみたいな
そんなことはないんだから
実際には もっと微妙なところなんです
人間がだらけと眠りがもう目的にして
あるいはそこは衝動にして生きてるだけで
もうどうしようもないと
頑張ってるんじゃないということを言ってるわけじゃないんです
で こちらはもうこれが良くないと
だらけない 眠気を断ち切るんだぞということで頑張ってるんです
そうするとすごく明るくて活発的であるはずなんですね
だからだらけと眠気を断ち切るということが目的にして何とかしている
だから即席の生き方とは全く違う生き方なんです
だから頑張らないと戒めておかないと
本来はだらけたい 眠気に負けたいという気持ちは本来の気持ちなんです
だから本来の気持ちに逆らうことだから
かなり戒めてやらないとできないんです
そこから簡単次にいきますね
十二 ウッダタ パレウッダタバヴィッサンティ
マヤメッタアヌッダタバヴィッサーミーティ
サッレコウカロニヨ 他人はよく混乱するが
我々は混乱しないようにと戒めましょうと
ウッダタというのは混乱しか言葉が出てこなかったんですけど
ほんとちょっとしたことで興奮するという状態なんです
もう興奮してしまっちゃうというか
混乱してしまっちゃう
だから興奮もいい言葉ではないし
混乱だけでもいい言葉でもないんです
だいたい興奮 混乱というのはほとんど一緒ですからね
いわゆる何が何だかわからない状態になるという状態なんです
人間というのは何か起きた瞬間にすぐこの興奮状態か混乱状態に陥っちゃうんです
何が何だかわからない状態にすぐ損じになっちゃうんです
それだけでも危険なんですけど
面白いこと これ期待するんですよ
この興奮状態を 期待してわざとそういうところを探し求めたりする
もっとひどいんです 例えば仏教ではものすごく私たちも反対するのは
例えば瞑想っていうのはいろんな宗教で教えているのに
やっぱり興奮状態 混乱状態
もう何が何だかわけのわからない状態をあえて作ってあげたりする
だから最悪だと我々は仏教の立場から言うんです
そんなのはなんとかの瞑想道場に行かなくたってもね
この宮さんに行けばいいのに
まだどこかのね 踊りとかいろいろやってるでしょうね
キャバレーやらいろいろ
そういうところに行ってね
もう踊ったり飲んだりしてあげると
もうまたカラオケもあるでしょうに
だから心理学的に見ると同じ結果出そうとしているだけ
形はもうあちらではなくてこちら行くんだぞというね
だからレストランにいろいろ料理があって
自分が一つ選ぶだけのことなんですね
自分の好みで 一応レストランに行ったのはご飯食べるためだから同じ結果なんですよ
どんな料理選んでも 美味しかった
お腹が満腹しましたという結果同じですから
だからこの人間っていうのはちょっとしたことで興奮してしまっちゃって
何がなんだかわからない状態になる
あるいは混乱してしまっちゃう
で もう突然電車でもカチンとブレーキかけちゃうとみんな混乱しますよ
飛行機でもなんとかに入っちゃうでしょ
エアポケットややつに入った途端
ドンと落ちたりもするでしょうに
その瞬間でガクンと混乱しちゃうんです
だって心は そこなんですね
私は一人で飛行機に乗っていると
そうやって落ちたりすると
もうまた気流に入っちゃって
もうガタガタガタガタガタガタガタガタ
もうもう何も倒れちゃうし
いられないしね で 私は文句もこちら側アスファルトちゃんと道路作っておけばどうなるんでしょうか？とかね
ひどい道路やと穴があったりとか
何がこれ？とか一人勝手にそうやって色々ぼんこと思いながら
自分はやることは全然変えようとはしない
で もし隣の人にそんなこと言っちゃうと怒られると思いますよ
こんなふざけたこと言うとくところじゃないんだと
本当はそういうところなんですけど
とったことはないんですけど
でもやっぱり人間というのは心はもうすぐもう
で 興奮する 混乱する 子供が殺されちゃうと親にね
あなた仕事減ったねとか
言ってみてください 高校はどうしますか？とか
もう悩まなくてもよかったとかね
で すっごくもうそうなるでしょうし
それはどうせ明らかに失礼な言葉なんですけど
やっぱり心の流れっていうのはもう決まっているというようなことなんですね
だから本当はそこら辺のもう一つ
全く逆の世界もあるんだよということを分かればね
子供が殺されちゃうとね
これで仕事がなくなったということと
あの子はね これから高校で苦労したりとかね
大学で苦労したり 仕事もなくて苦労したりと
浪人したりとかね そういうこともなくなったんだと
幸せなままで亡くなっちゃったんだからね
いいんじゃないんですかという風にも
それも事実ですよ いい加減じゃないんですよ
子供は幸せなままで 何も苦労知らないで
もう親に守られて可愛がってもらっているところで
もう自分のどうせ人は死ぬんだからね
だから苦労して死ぬか苦労しないで死ぬかっていうぐらいの差でしょうに
大人になったんだからって
何か別にそんな大胆なことを得られるということでもないでしょうし
もし小さいところからもうものすごいもう桁違う抜群の才能を見せているならば
また話は別ですけどね
天才的なもう能力を見せているんだったら
早く死んでかわいそうやと
いろいろなことができたんではないかということになりますけど
また見てください 天才的な能力ある人というのは大体歳ぐらいでもう死んじゃいますでしょ
だからもう結局そんなもんですよ
天才的な能力を持って生まれる子は
やることは大体そこら辺でやって終わっているんですよ
それで自然に死んじゃうんです
ひどい病気にかかったりとかね
体が壊れたりして死んでしまっちゃいますよ
だからほとんどね もう天才っていうのはもう稀な存在でしょうし
ほとんど普通の人間だから
大人になったんだからといってね
別に そんなに面白くことをするわけじゃないでしょう
だからそこで我々はもう変な事実を見てないんで
自分ももう大人ですから
自分がすごいことをやってるんですかと
じゃないでしょうに ただもうだらだらと生きているだけでしょうし
それを子供を経験してほしいというのはね
だからやっぱり ただ決まってるパターンで考えるんじゃなくて
もう一つ逆さまの思考もあります
この面白いこと この逆さまな思考が真理なんです
だから とりあえず悟ってないならば
どちらでも考えておいた方がもう結構いいんですよ
そこまでここで言っちゃうと時間なくなりますから
このウッダタっていうのは簡単に興奮
混乱する状態で生きているんですけど
これ結構踏ん張らないと興奮
混乱しない状態は保つことはできないんですよ
だから我々は興奮しない
混乱しない精神を育てるぞと
この仏道を歩もうとする個人が頑張るんです
で 二十三はヴェーチキッチン
パレーヴェーチキッチーバビッサンティマイメッタティンナヴィチキッチャーバビッサーミーティサッレーコーカラーニーヨ
みんな懐疑的であるが
我々は懐疑を断ち切るようにと戒めますという
懐疑的なんですね だいたい人間っていうのは
懐疑的っていうのは何でしょうかね
やっぱり知ろう調べようという
しっかり知ろうではないかという気持ちがないんですね
もしかするとそうでしょうねとかね
例えばもうまあ政治家はみんなもう嘘つきでしょとか
もうすごい大雑把で言って
本当に私知ってますか？って言うと
知らないし 会ったこともないし
政治家ね なのに そうやって言ってしまっちゃって
で それ例えばよく私に何回ももう攻撃文書あったんですけど
どんな宗教も同じこと言ってるんではないかと
本人がすごい頭のいい知恵のことを言ってるつもりなんですけどね
だから私はものすごく厳しく選別して喋るでしょうしね
だからこんなことはないんだ
誰でも同じこと言ってるんだ
ある人は私は慈悲なんか仏教以外はないんだよとはっきり言ったんです
そんなこと言ったって
どんな宗教でも教えているんではないかと
本当に怒らせないでいられないんですよ
私は厳密に調べて もう本何冊書いたっても書ききれないほどのデータに基づいて調べて
客観的に調べて言っていることなんです
あのバカの壁は必要やと言ったのはもう単純じゃないんですよ
私はあの本はあまり日本語わからないんだから読み違いしたっていうね
それ甘い話じゃないんです
ただ もうものすごい思考の世界だから
そこら辺はまあいいやということに
しただけのことなんですね
そこで私は長い論文で自分の弁解をしなければいけない
なぜそういうことを言ったのかと
だからこの論言ってるんではないかといったら
私はそれにはもうかなり四百ページぐらいになる本を書かなくちゃいけないんですよ
なんでまるっきりもう完全無知な人にそこまで努力する意思あるんですかね
いくらか見込みがあるんだったらね
頑張ってもいいんですけど
だから聖書にああいう言葉が出ているところは全てまとめてまで見たんだから
ヒンドゥー教でジャイナ教でイスラム教で
どんな例えばそれが扱っているんでしょうかと
これでやっぱりこういう慈悲は仏教は釈尊釈迦は教えてないんだよというのはね
そういう結論ですよ しかし
世界は何でも知ってるんだというなんか錯覚というか
なんか何て言いますか
あれは もう何でも知ってるんだという安心感というかね
自信というかね そういうもので
もう何の丁重もなく いろいろなんか頭の良さそうな
しかし我々から見ればもうこれはダメやという言葉をよく言うんですよ
で これが懐疑なんですよ
ある方がずっと私を責めていたんだから
あなたはすごく排他的で
仏教しか真理を語ってないという態度で喋りますけど
私は絶対それは認めませんと
私は全ての宗教家が同じ真理を語っていると思っているんだよと
だからみんな一緒になってほしいと
これは誠に残念ですと
あなたの話はと言うんですけど
すごい立派に聞こえるでしょうね
私はもう もう完全なゴミで誠に残念ですと回答するんです
ゴミの中でもなんとか拾っちゃえば何かあるんで
これもないという状態なんです
もう完全なゴミは でも本人にはそれを理解しない
本人はちゃんとした物事をわかって言っているような気分でいるんですけど
これ懐疑が作る危険なんです
調べなさいよということなんですよ
だから調べるんじゃなくて
すぐすぐ結論出して この
これはスイーピングという全部包括的にまとめて結論出したくなるんですね
これが仏教は懐疑と言うんですよ
役に立たんと そんなもんで
例えばどこかの子供が人殺し
今頃の子供たちは 冗談でそんなことはね
子供は小学生が人を殺しちゃっても
いまだに小学生は可愛いんですよ
別に そういうふうなことで
なんかえらい頭が良さそうに見えるでしょうに
もう散々もうディスカッションするわ
今頃はね 子供たちはこういうことでこうなってる
まるっきりもう聞いていられないほど偏見で嘘ばっかり羅列しちゃうんですよ
だからどういうふうに調べるかということははっきりしないし
はっきりとそのケースをスタディして
なぜそうなったのかというと
それでそれはそのあと特定のその子供の思考パターンかもしれません
あるいはそういうふうな思考パターンはかなりあるかもしれません
それなりに結論を出さなくちゃいけないんです
だからそれがないんだから
また返って事実上ね もう何でも調べるということも不可能でしょうし
これで事実上何でも調べることは不可能だからといって懐疑的になってはならないんですよ
だから私はバカの壁というのは生半可ではなくて作らなくちゃいけないんですよ
世の中に起こり得ることを何でも徹底的に調べるというのは調べようがないでしょうに
どこかの小学生が人を殺したんだからといって
その子供に会うことは絶対できない
その子供が何喋ってるかと言ったって
もう漏れる情報しかない
それもほとんどジャーナリストの作品でしょうし
警察は情報は全然出してくれない
現場検証しようとしたって
それは警察だけの 何でしたっけ
特権であって 一般の人にはできない
ですから 事実上そういうのは調べるということは不可能なんですよ
だからそこら辺で壁を作るんですよ
本当にどうなったかって
これは知り得る方法がないんだからいいんじゃないんですか
そこら辺で しかし 人を殺すことだけはよくない
子供を大事に守りましょうと
子供は立派に道徳的な人間になるように育てなくちゃいけない
これどうすればいいかと
そこら辺で研究すればいいでしょうに
そこら辺で知恵を開拓すればいいです
ちゃんと壁作るんですよ
壁作ってしっかりした知恵を育てるんです
だから与良先生は壁があるんだぞと発見しただけで
それからどうするかっていうところは
そこら辺の研究には入ってないんです
だと思う まだわからないんですけど
そういうことで この懐疑っていうのは
何でもまとめてこんなもんだという風に決めつけちゃう
あるいは あるいはかえって逆に壁ばっかしでわかりませんとかね
そんなのは興味ありませんとかね
私は忙しいとかね という状態ももう一番ひどい悪い懐疑的な状態なんですね
そういうのはよくないと
で どう見たっても人間っていうのは早く結論出したいんですよ
これが懐疑的なんです
だから出て 何年でも何十年でも何百年でも調べるぞと言ったっても
これまた正しくはないんです
早く結論出したいんだからで手抜きしてはいけないんですよ
これが人間に普通にある精神状態なんです
これの反対で仏教を実践しようとする個人が頑張ってみるんです
知るべきものは知るんだぞと
そこまでは結論はつけませんよと
明確に調べるんだよと
言うと壁作るんです 何を調べて何を調べないかと
こんなのは世の中で当然あるんですよ
避けられません 壁は 例えば
ドイツの歴史を研究しますよと
ドイツの歴史に対してすごくいい本を書いてやろうではないかと伊藤が選んだら
なんで中国の歴史を研究するんですかね
なんで数学の本を読んでるんですかね
なんで小説読んでるんですか？そうすると時間の無駄でしょうに
だから中国の 中国の歴史を勉強することも置いておいて
数学の本も置いておいて
小説を読むことも置いておいて
ドイツ歴史に関わるところは全部研究する
その時はやっぱり古いジャーマン語を勉強しなくちゃいけないんだったら
それもやる ドイツ人がオランダ人と関係性が持っていたんだったら
もうオランダ語を勉強してみるとかね
カトリック教の歴史はかなりドイツの改訂に関係あったら
カトリック教の歴史も勉強してみると
そこら辺で勉強したってもいいんだけど
で 漫画読んだり小説読んだりする時にはちゃんと壁を作っておかないと
だから 知るためには壁が必要なんです
そうね そういうことで
そういうことを何もしないで
ただやっぱね 「そうでしょう」とか「だって嘘でしょう」とかね 「
本当？」とかね という生き方も回避主義なんですね
「嘘」「本当」って  大体「嘘」「本当」「マジ」とかね
そういうのは回避主義から出てくる言葉なんですね 「
あらまあ」とか「びっくりしました」とかね
だからそっちの日常は当たり前ですよ
そんなのは だからこれで人間の生き方はそういう生き方であって
仏道をやろうとする個人が
一人が全く逆な世界に頑張ってみるんだという話になるんです
次にコーダナ 怒る 怒ることですね
それは分かりやすいですね
我々心は一応怒るようになってます
嫌なものに出会ったら怒ると決まってるパターンですよ
嫌なものに出会って喜んじゃったっていうことはありえないんです
侮辱されても楽しくてたまらなかったとかね
ありえないんですよ 心が動くパターンというのは全部もう決まってるパターンで
この決まってるパターンで行かないんです
仏道は そこで自分が怒らないということに
当然怒らないと戒める場合は
嫌なことに出会っても怒らないってことになってるんですよ
それで改革的なんです
美しい花を見て「私は怒りませんよ」と言うとバカバカらしい話でしょうね
気に入っている人に出会って「私は怒りませんよ」とかね
バカバカしい話で だから怒るのは気に入らない人に出会うと怒る
嫌なことに出会うと怒る
やりたくないことをやらせると怒る
折り合わない人と寄り合うことになると腹が立ってくる
それは自然のパターンで
そこで怒らないんですよ
だから全くも逆の生き方をするんですよ
だから結構頑張らないとできるものじゃないんです
怒り それからウパナーハっていうのは恨むことですね
なかなか怒りが入っちゃうと
なかなか消えないんですよ
もうずっと続けちゃう
それはウパナーハっていう状態ですね
マッキーっていうのは他者の徳を軽視する
これも全ての人類にあるんですよ
なんかどこかでケチつけたくなるんですね
人のいいところに で パラシンっていうのは張り合うことですね
張り合ったりする ここで
一応日本訳は注釈書を参考にして出したものやと思いますけどね
それでいうと  パラシン
マッキー パラシンはセットですからね
やっぱり マッキー パラシンの意味がないな
で 張り合うことっていうのはいいことだとみんな思ってるし
すぐ張り合ったりはするしね
で これも生命ではね 本来添えてるんですよ
子供頃よく見えるでしょう
大人になってくるとあるんだけど
なかなかできない場合は抑えてるだけのことで
その性格はあります すぐ嫉妬することですね
これも自然法則ですよ
自分より何かね 他人がうまくっていると嫉妬してしまっちゃうんですね
で 物惜しみがありまして
で これ全て自然法則として見なきゃダメなんです
物惜しみっていうのはごく普通自然なんです
自分のものっていうのは他人にはあげたくはないんです
だから私にも一つ欲しいと思った瞬間でも
物惜しみは機能しているんです
三十番目のサタっていうのは見栄を張ることと訳しましたけどね
するがすごいという意味でもありますね
[咳]三十一番目の道徳はマーヤヴィンということで
この まあないものを見せるという意味で
なかなか似て サッママーヤヴィっていうのはセット用語で
マッシューカラシーはセット用語でほとんど一緒なんです
一応 サッタという言葉とマーヤヴィという言葉というのはほとんど意味としては同じなんですね
サッタといえばちょっと硬いですよ
見栄張ることなんですけど
ちょっとやり方は マーヤヴィというとちょっと滑らかで
かなり芸術的に人を騙したりするって
で  三十二番目は  頑固であること
これも あの 俗世間で頑固な人も頑固でない人もいるんではないかと思いますけど
これは仏教の立場から言うんだから
全ての生命は頑固でなければ成り立たない話なんです
ですから 全ての生命は頑固であるという解釈をすると
お釈迦様は考えたことになるんです
我々の世界で見ると みんな頑固じゃないんですよ
まあ頑固な人もいますけど
みんな頑固わけじゃないという風に俗世間ではそう思ってます
でもこの経典ではそうじゃなくて
みんな頑固なのに 私一人で頑固にならないように頑張っているんだという論理構成だから
それでどんな時点で 時点で
どんな角度で見る尺度で見ると
全ての生命は頑固になるでしょうかっていうところの解釈が正しい解釈になるんです
これはこの頑固っていうことは自分の自我のことであって
自分考えていること 自分の判断
自分の好き嫌いっていうのは
もう他人にはいちいち言われて欲しくないんですね
大体人間っていうのは自分を変えたいという気持ちはもとないんです
自分の人格っていうのは
本当にあの ジェームスさんのアレンさんの考え方を借りて言っているわけじゃなくて
ブッダが言ってるんだから
自分の意思で自分があえて作っている性格なんです
自分の性格はきちんと淡々と自分で組み立てている
自分の意思で 自分の考え方で組み立てている性格なんです
これは誰かに変えようと言ったとしても
せっかく作ったものは変えたくないんですよ
だから自分の今の人格っていうのは決して変えたくはない
だから全ての生命っていうのは頑固なんです
それで問題点 でも どう言っても人の性格っていうのはどんどん変わっていくでしょうにと
もう変わってはいきますけど
それは その人が自分で変えていくことなんですけど
それも考えでやってるわけじゃないんですよ
ただ 最初に人格を作った同じ感情でずっと作りっぱなし組み立てっぱなしなんです
感情でやってるんです
だから変わるのは変わるんだけど
頑固さには頑固さは消えたわけじゃないんです
例えば すごく欲張りな人がいるとします
そこで物事を考える場合は
欲張りという感情で物事を判断したり
考えたり 生きたりする
それで彼の人格が出来上がっちゃうんですよ
欲張り的な人格が ここであんたこういう硬くて頑固で欲張りではないかと人に言われるかもしれません
でも変えません その人は
そこでさらに生きてみると
いろんなことに欲を出したところで
結構ひどい目に遭ったりする
欲を満たすんじゃなくて
自分持っていた財産もある人が
かなり有名な人で 日本で欲張りでものすごい借金になってしまったんですね
で 何億何億とか 今貯金があるんだぞと威張っていた人が
突然もう何億も赤字になったとかね
ということもあるんだから
その時は性格変わるんですよ
どういう風に変わるかというと
同じ欲張り感情なんですよ
あ こういう風に手を出しちゃうと
もうダメやと じゃあこれから気をつけてこういう風に生きてみるんだぞと決めるんです
結局欲張り同じなんです
欲張りの感情はそのままなんです
だからある面で性格は変えてますけど
変えるパターンがずっと同じなんですよ
大胆に 180度変えろということはないんです
それで せっかく自分が作った自分の人格だから
これはもう変えたくはない
自分の内心の衝動でも変えたくはないし
外から言われる話でも変えたくはない
だから人間 自分を変えてちょうだいと言っていろんなところに行くんだけど
あの宗教に行くことと同じなんですよ
何でいろんなところに行っていろんなアドバイスを受けているのに
訓練もしているのに変わらないんですか？と
自分の問題 変えたくない
変えたくないんだからなんです
で そういうところで頑固ということが普遍的な真理として成り立つ
生命にある普遍的な真理
そこで仏道は この普遍的な真理に全く逆らって個人が頑張ってみるんです
アティマーニは高慢ということで
このアティマーニ タッダアティマーニドゥッパチャ
そこ３セットは同じなんですよ
自我というところから現れてくることで
こちらで 3つに分けてるだけで
例えばこのコーダウパナーヒマッキーパラシイッスキーマッチャリというところは怒りから出てくるもので
そうやってこの裏のセットのカテゴリを覚えておけば分かりやすいんです
というか覚えやすいんです
サカマーヤーヴィタッダアティマーニドゥッパチャというところは
自我から出てくる非道徳的な言動です
それで高慢というのは説明しなくてもわかるでしょうし
どんな生命でも特に高慢でしょうし
で 高慢にならないように
これものすごく難しいんですよ
自我が高慢作るんだから
この仏道をやろうと思ったってまだまだ自我があるでしょうに
だからかなり厳しいことなんです
高慢にならないということは
生半可な気持ちでできるものじゃないんです
ドゥッパチャというのは
いろいろ考えたところで反抗的っていう風に一応訳を決めましたけど
いわゆる言うことを聞いてくれないんですね
言い訳するわ 反論するわ
だってという言葉持ってくるわ
その性格なんですね 我々はどんな失敗しても
だってという気持ち持ってるんですよ
これがドゥッパチャということなんですね
だから瞑想の場合はこういうところは本当にものすごい大変ですよ
だからこの私にしてみれば
もう 1日2日でものすごいなんとかなってほしいんですけど
それは 1日2日ということは 1年2年でもなくならないでしょうしね
だからそういう性格の問題なんですね
時々みんなものすごく知識そうな顔をしてきてね
あの ずっとこの頃いろいろ仕事で忙しかった
疲れたんだから だと思いますけど
随分眠気がありまして
瞑想中はとかね もうこちらにはもう立ち入りできないので
それでこれでドゥッパチャなんですよ
もう言い訳してるんだから
もう直れないんですよ
でも誰もそれぐらいのことちゃんとした話ではないかと
本当に疲れているんでしょうと
だから眠気が出て当たり前という態度取るでしょ
俗世間の考え方とブッダの世界っていうのはもう噛み合わない
で 我々見るのはもう当たり前ではなくてドゥッパチャと
聞くだけでもものすごく嫌な気分になるんですね
時間が無駄だ 私はどうしたってもという他の人が次に来てくだすって
あんたはもう帰れという気持ちになるんですよ
要するに先生 自己弁解ってこと
うん だから自己弁解する気持ち
気分がもうずっとあるでしょうに
ない人いないでしょうに
だからそれがこちらでいうこの
ドゥッパチャ 反抗的という
だから自分もそういう自己弁解する気持ちを持っていて
仏道を歩もうかなと思っちゃうと
これ真面目なくちゃいけないんですよ
だからここやってみると真面目にもういきなりもう爆発したような感じで自己改革はしますよ
たった項目でも真面目に考えてみちゃうと
自我が爆発して瞬時に自己改革なんです
例えば何があっても自己弁解だけはしませんという態度で
物事生きてみようとすると
ものすごくもう頭側はもう見方っていうのは度変えない限りはできるものじゃない
それだけで仏教の世界も現れているんだから
で 仏道はスワチャになりますね
素直になりますという
何か悪いと何か言われて
あ そう なるほどって そんな素直に聞くというね
素直に聞くということは
ただ何でも言われっぱなしという意味じゃないんですよ
それじゃないんです しっかりとなぜ悪いか相手は説得しない限りはね
で はもうパーパミット
悪友と付き合うということで
これがみんなやってないでしょ
でも この経典の立場からはみんなやってるんだっていうことにならないとダメなんです
悪友と付き合うことはみんなやっているんだと
と取らないと理解できないんです
勝手に理解何でもできるんだけど
釈尊自身が我々に教えている大胆な改革プログラムにはならないんです
俗世間のレベルでもお釈迦様言いますけどね
悪い人と付き合うなよとかね
それぐらいの話ではないんです
それでパパミッタ ミッタっていうのは付き合うことでしょうに
我々は付き合う場合は必ずしも折り合いができる人と付き合うんですよ
自分の性格に合う人と付き合うんですよ
はめる人と付き合うんですよ
だったらパパミッタで決まってるでしょうに
だって自分の人格に合う人でしょ
わがままで高慢で見栄張ったりしている
そこで自分が人格を構成しているでしょうに
付き合おうとしてればちゃんと折り合いができる
性格がぴったしはめる人と付き合うんですよ
ということは 明らかにその人もパパミッタなんです
というわけで 人類が悪友と付き合ってるっていうことになるんです
それで私は善友と付き合うぞということっていうのは
ものすごい難しいことで
自分の人格を全く認めない人と付き合うんだから
一片も自分を褒めてくれない人と付き合うことだから
ものすごい厳しいんです
で カルヤナミッタって言えば
定義がまた逆にあって
ブッダやら釈尊やら仏弟子たちやら
悟った人々やら仏教を語る人々やら
そういう人々に決まってるんです
誰でもカルヤナミッタとはじゃないんです
この場合は そこで誰も悟った人は誰でもいないんだったら
自分一人で仏教の勉強して頑張りたいと思ったら
カルヤナミッタはお釈迦様なんです
経典はお釈迦様がおっしゃっていることだから
それで随分カルヤナミッタでお釈迦様は自分の専有にしておく
でもお釈迦様は一片も自分やっていることを認めてくれないんです
かなりもう厳しくしつけをする
だからそこを付き合うのは難しいんです
そこで経典がわからないところで
また勉強してみると サーリプッタ尊者の経典を見つけて
よく分かります サーリプッタ尊者大体注釈的に説法するんだからね
よく分かりましたと ありがたいなと
これからもサーリプッタ尊者の経典があったら調べてみますよということになると
自分の専有がサーリプッタ尊者になる
ということで 人格改革するためのカルヤナミッタだから
性格的には折り合わないのは決まってるんです
というわけで 俗世間ではみんな悪友と付き合っているのに
私は一人だけでも善友と付き合うことには頑張る
チャレンジすると うーん
なんかここら辺でやめた方がいいんじゃないかなと思いますけど
やめましょう  では 講義はこれで終わりにしたいと思います
誰かご質問などございますでしょうか
今の話の中で出てきたお話について
項目についていろいろ出てきましたけど
何かご質問など ここの辺がわからないなとか
自分はこう思うとかっていうことがありましたら出していただけますでしょうか
善人ぶるっていう言葉ありましたよね
偽善者ぶるっていう意味
自分がいい人間をやってみせることだからね
偽善者っていうことなんですね
偽善と言えば 日本語で一般的に使う言葉だから
ここら辺でちょっと私はお互いに話し合って
全部一言葉一言葉選んだものだから
私の私はよく使ってます
善人かぶりとかなんとかとかね
これはなんで日本で偽善という言葉あるにも関わらず使いますかというと
ちょっと意味ニュアンスが違いますからね
だからそこのニュアンスはどうなのかなと思って
わかる いい人間になとね
見せることなんですよ
そこはみんな気分的にはありますよ
持ってます 私はいい人間だよと
ちゃんとやってますよと
あれ自己正当化することなんですね
あれパーリ語でマヤヴィでしょ
マヤヴィということは
もう直訳するともうあれでしょ
何て言いますか 手品師っていうことなんです
みんな手品師や [笑い] いい言葉だと思って
手品 嘘のことを本当のように見せるテクニックだから
そうそう  あの 慈経に あの
パガッパとアッパガッパでしたっけ？が出てきますよね
あの 裏表のある人間みたいな
あれとはまた違う？ 似ています
同じです であの 解釈すると変わっちゃいますけどね
アッパガッパ パガッパっていうのは
あれは あの 解釈は出家に合わせて言ってるんですよ
で 出家はなんかすごくいい顔をして落ち着いているような感じで歩いたり座ったりすると
やっぱり心の中でこれでみんな尊敬してくれるだろうとかね
もういろいろお布施くれるだろうとかね
で もう計算しているんですよ
それはすっごい汚い生き方だと
それはパガッパということで
そんなことを人に褒めてもらいたい
人に あの たくさんお布施欲しいというね
気持ちでやるんじゃないよと
で これやってますよ その気持ち
なぜかというと 慈悲っていうのはものすごい力でしょう
これ あらゆる生命を引き寄せる力だから
生命が引き寄ってくるということが
もう採算に溢れるという意味なんです
だからやっています 実際には
で あの ここだけの話なんですけどと言っちゃうと
もう日本国みんなにバレますからね
で あ これはいいことを見つけたスマナサーラ長老がするなんて言われたらなかなか倒れません
いくら抗議したっても
[笑い]それも言っておりますけど
あの あるミャンマーからあるお坊さんが来たんですよ
完全お歳のお坊さんとしては立派な方でね
文句はないんですけどね
お坊さんダメということを言っていただくはないんですけど
まあ私よりはしっかりもう屈強--もうなくなりましたけどね
あの しっかりとお坊さんとしての
私は日本にいるんだからね
もう全然お釈迦様おっしゃってる程度の生活もできないし
そんな問題ないんですけど
そこら辺はミャンマーの社会だからね
ちゃんとしっかりしてる立派な方ですけど
慈悲の実践者ということで
はい それは自分の主義というか
悪くはないんだけど これかなりもう布施やら何から何まで
そのお坊さんがいるところはものすごい豊か
溢れている そこで信者さんも
それで自分たちもそうやって豊かさに恵まれるようにということで
サーっとそちらに群がったりする
こちらに来ても人々に祝福して病気治してあげるとか
そういうことはやったりする
確かに戒律を守っていて
しっかり慈悲の瞑想を瞑想としてやっているんだから
こういう結果もあるんだけど
どうせそのお坊さんに祝福されちゃうと
それなりに病気は和らげたり
なくなったりはします
でもこれは他力な-- 他力だから
病気治っても完治っていうことにはなりませんしね
その力がある間はそのお坊さんに対してありがたいという気持ちがある間は病気はないんだけど
忘れちゃうとまた元に戻っちゃうしね
だからそんなことやるなよっていうのがブッダの道なんです
慈悲はそういうけしからんな目的に使うなよと
これはもう大変な尊い
いやもう人間の道であって
ということだから もうアッパガッパっていうのは否定-- じゃあなくて
パガッパっていうことは否定してアッパガッパっていうことは推奨している
慈悲を実践する前に そういうところでまず注意しなさいと
一人の人からでも褒めてもらいたいという気持ちは絶対ダメなんです
今のお坊さんがどうしてパガッパなのかっていうことなんですか
パガッパ だからそちらに-- 仏教
これは出家の定義だから
お釈迦様の立場から見るとそうなるんですよ
なんでそのお坊さんがそれだけやるつもりになってるんですかね
それ お釈迦様にはカンカン怒られるでしょうね 「
なんでお前出家したんですか」と 「
欲を捨てて解脱するためではないか」と
という風にお釈迦様だったらものすごい怒られるはずなんです
でも両立してやる場合は素晴らしいとは言うんです
解脱を目指して頑張りながら
何と言いますか 慈悲の瞑想もする
死の瞑想もするということは
それは素晴らしいよと
その場合 お釈迦様名前まで付けてくれるんですよ
まあ慈悲の  達人や死の随伴の達人やとかね
それをお釈迦様に褒められて名前を付けられる場合は
その人々は解脱をもうメインロードであって
それにはどんな車で乗っていくかっていうことなんです
それで あの人はポルシェ
あの人はベンツ あの人はシャワレやとかいうだけの話で
俺の車はシャワレだからといって
これを磨いたりどこかに駐車場停まってると
これはバカにされちゃうんです
これ確かにシャワレかもしれませんだけど
で 結果出すためにはもうインチキでは効かないんです
だから真面目に慈悲の瞑想しないと
あれほどの結果は出せないと思います
だからあのお坊様をなんかみんな神様みたいな感じで
随分もう丁寧に扱ったりしていたんですから
それはそれで悪くはないんですよ
我々の一般的な仏教の目から見ると
だから私はあえてこの定義はもうギリギリと出家に対する定義なんです
パガッパ パガッパの定義は
で 俗世間のレベルでも
まあやっぱり掃除機に人を助ける方がいいんですよ
何か見返り目指すよりはね
だから俗世間の定義になってくると
見返りを 見返りを目指してやるものではありませんという定義-- 解釈はいいと思いますね
パガッパはどうやって訳したらわかりませんとか
あれは見返りを期待せずというふうに訳した方がわかりやすいんです
裏表なくとかっていうのは
うーん まあね その時その時頭に浮かぶ言葉だから
訳すの難しいんですよ
私たちに言われたら 私もいろんな定義知ってるんだから
もう 頭をあっち行ったりこっち行ったり
どこら辺でもう切るかというところでね
まあ悩んだりもするし
ぴったしっていう言葉は出てこないね
だから裏表なしでもよろしいし
掃除機っていうことだから
その場合はね 掃除機っていう場合
別なパーリ語もありますけど
見返りを期待せずというふうな訳も悪くはないと思いますけどね
[笑い]いろいろ質問してもいいんです
質問した方が生々しく説明できます
ただ 私は勝手に喋ると
ものすごくもう純粋論理論になりますよ
ご利益主義の話があったんですが
ご利益っていうのはあるあって言っているんですか？なくても言ってるんですか？ それもね
難しいことでね ご利益の方程式はありますよ
その方程式に沿っていくとご利益はあります
方程式は簡単ですよ 善因
善果 悪因 悪果という方程式なんです
例えば 神社に行って灯籠を奉納する
百万円ぐらいかかるかもしれません
これでうまく商売がうまくいったと言っても
あれはどう解釈するかと
やっぱりこの神社の神様ということは我々は言わないんですよ
あんたは欲を捨てて 何か人々のために
神社でもちゃんか 鐘楼なんか作っちゃえば
かっこいいでしょうし
見る人々も喜ぶでしょうしね
場所は綺麗になるでしょうし
全く悪いこととは言えない
で 自分が物惜しみをやめて
まあせっかくだからということで奉納する
その善因がその人には善果を作ってくれます
そこで俗世間ではご利益
ご利益言うんですけど
仏教はそう使わない そういう大雑把なことは
ご利益を漢字で見れば別に問題はないんですけど
気分では違う意味を持ってるでしょ
ご利益と言えば なんかわけもわからないところでいいことを言っていたという意味で
ご利益という言葉だから
私はそれに反対しているのであって
漢字に反対しているわけじゃないんです
ただの利益ですからね
例えばよくあることで
題目を唱えるともうあらゆるご利益がついてくると
あれは嘘です しかし ある人が汚れた心をやめて尊い気分になりまして
これはすごい薬湯やとか宇宙曼荼羅やとか
くだらん妄想に基づいて
まあもう題目をずっと唱える
それでその人はその間では妄想に惹かれてるかもしれませんだけど
無知に惹かれてるかもしれませんだけど
怒りはないわ 欲はないわ
清々しい気分でいるわ
心それなりに綺麗なんですよ
だからある 分ぐらい頑張ったんです
それには結果出ます もし心がその間で綺麗になったならば
だからこのご利益はありますけど
それは善因善果 悪因悪果という方程式で起こるんであって
善因作らなきゃ善果には決してなりません
だから題目唱えたらご利益あるんだよということは嘘
であって 善根作ればご利益あるんだよというふうに言わなくちゃいけないんです
般若心経を写経するとご利益あるんだよということは嘘であって
心を込めて殺念をやめて
ありがたい気持ちで清々しい気持ちで写経すると
これには三分ぐらいかかるかもしれません
この三分心を管理した善行為によって
その分はご利益を得られる
このご利益はまちまちのはそういうわけなんです
別にご利益はまちまちで
神様は気分屋さんというわけじゃないんです
あの神様はあの人には子供を授けてくれたんだけど
私にはやってくれなかったとかね
と言っちゃうと もう神様えらい気分屋さんということになるんですよ
それじゃなくて ちゃんとした方程式なんです
善因善果 悪因悪果というのは
だから自業自得というまた方程式があるでしょ
仏教の方程式だからね
だからご利益と言うべきかと
ご利益はご利益なんですけど
自分で頑張っていたものなんです
他人がくれたものじゃないんです
自業自得なんです そういうわけで
ご利益本当にありますか？という単純な質問にはね
なかなかあるともないとも言えないんですね
だから終わらないんですよ
例えばカトリック教であろうがイスラム教だが
みんなそれなりのご利益のお祈りしたりするでしょうね
まるっきりなかったらみんなやめちゃうでしょう
でもなんとなくないわけでもないんですよ
それでみんな誤解しちゃうんですね
やっぱりこの神様がやってくれたと言っちゃうと
神様は必ずいい気分でもうならし者になっちゃうんですよ
だってイラク人も神を信仰しているし
アフガン人も神を信仰しているし
結果は何なのかというと最悪でしょうに
でもそんなことではありませんというのは我々言うんですね
やっぱり宗教はどうであろうと
もうほんのわずかでも
心はなんとかもう工夫してでも綺麗になったら
その分でいい結果が出てくる
では終了しましょう  ではこれで終了したいと思います